hey guys welcome to ask ij uh
yep intro please
[Music]
so before i start this episode this is a
note to all my fantastic florida friends
hi guess what i'm going to be in florida
orlando florida to be exact on march
26th and 27th for playlist live playlist
live is an awesome event sponsored by
district lines and i hope that all of
you can make it i will put all of the
information that you need to know about
this event below in the description i'll
be there a bunch of other peeps will be
there so hey i hope to see you there now
for some questions so i get a lot of
comments that says justine please put me
in this episode but you actually don't
say anything other than please put me in
this episode so i think i'm gonna start
a new segment cub please put me in the
south sky j episode and this is only for
youtube comments so if you want to be in
a future episode of ask ij just leave a
comment saying please put me in the
episode and here's our wonderful please
put me in this episode uh
featured commenters
facebook question kate wants me to teach
her how to dougie
okay
um
let me get back to you on that one my
favorite cartoon some of you may be a
little too young for this but it was a
cartoon called doug
doug funny
may or may not have had a small crush on
him then i realized he was a cartoon and
it was just never gonna work out alex
this is a super strange question if i
found the perfect guy and he had hairy
teeth would i still like him i mean i'm
not a judgmental person but
i mean
i don't really know if he would have a
dentist or a salon
to maybe get that taken care of
how did you even think of that sarah
asks if i am truly justine or if i'm a
robot
my dream car obviously the back to the
future delorean daily with question big
pop five five six once another one
switch to verizon and you know i'm
actually not sure my contract isn't up
for a while so
when my contract is up then i'm gonna
decide for those of you who are on
verizon has anyone got the new iphone
yet if you have leave a comment i'd love
to see what you guys think of it so far
bloody 5'4 how do i get around town
i healey obviously
i'm getting shin splits because you use
like this weird like muscle right here
to hold your legs up and stuff i'm
telling you man
this isn't a walk in the park this is a
wheel
really leaning backwards to go forward
is kind of terrifying so this is kind of
funny because benny was asking if i
liked green tea or yerba mate pure
empowerment and as a matter of fact as
he asked that question let me tell you
what i was drinking
this and you know what else is hilarious
it says on the box
that it is a magical mint
salt
sold
wow
that was not supposed to happen big
trenton what is my favorite map on call
of duty and what's my favorite gun my
favorite gun is the famas or the enfield
or the ak-47 but i'm kind of also a fan
of the commando my favorite map is one
of the new ones stadium for xbox those
of you who aren't on xbox probably don't
have the new map pack yet but if you do
sweet what do you think
oh gosh you want to play xbox so bad
right now i can't pronounce your name
but you are asking me if i have any sexy
shades and yes as a matter of fact i do
and these are pretty
sexy
what do you think
so ricky wants to know which sister do i
like better brienne or jenna are you
kidding like i'm really gonna go and
pick my favorite sister you are not a
very good sibling twitter question
eightfold asks what's one thing that i
miss about being home well i miss
pittsburgh as a city i absolutely love
pittsburgh but i also miss my family and
my friends beast 3703 wants to know what
i think of nicki minaj and will i wrap
her part and bottoms up well first of
all i'm probably gonna fail at rapping
but i will try and second i think she's
very talented yo could i get that tron
could i get that running could i get
that coat could i get that honey can i
get a margarita on the rock rock rock
can i get that salt all around the rim
[Music]
if i was banned from an apple store due
to dancing what would i do
obviously i would just go dance
somewhere else
[Music]
maybe dance in an abandoned parking
garage
ha ha men who i'm probably
mispronouncing your name wants to know
if i'll be there valentine and yes i
will
happy valentine's day to you thank you
guys for watching this episode of ask
guys now my question of the video is
coming from actually susie who asked me
what my favorite cartoon is or was so
what's your favorite cartoon just leave
a comment below and be sure to also
leave a comment saying please put me in
the ask ij video for the new wonderful
please put me in a skyjam video segment
i love you guys thanks for watching i
hope to see all of you in orlando on
march 26 and march 27th and if i don't
i'll see you guys on the internet be
sure to check out all of my other
youtube channels here and uh subscribe
to this channel for more of my really
amazing videos
really amazing so amazing so
okay